je suis assistant du professeur fall a
depuis maintenant plusieurs mois
oui mais voilà des plans de cette
invention ont disparu alors l'assistant
du professeur a besoin d' aide la
famille d'achats frier à 30 minutes pour
les trouver il participe à un escaping
dire pas de compétences particulières en
skis et bien une chouette observateurs
fouillé et surtout il faut s'organiser
en équipe ya des moments où on va
rechercher fouiller tout seul mais dès
qu'on est bloqué bien pensé à se
regrouper en équipe se poser des
questions c'est chose faite pour la
famille fuyant courtoises avec un record
à la clé ils ont eu moins de 24 minutes
a trouvé ce qu'il cherchait c'est un bon
moyen de créer une bonne cohésion
familiale de travailler en équipe
c'est pas évident on est on est aidé on
est soutenus donc non ça va on passer un
moment en famille
c'est la première fois au ces que j'en
fais un escape game organisé dans le
cadre des lui 10 days les jeux avaient
pris possession de la commanderie
dans une autre salle on découvrait des
jeux de ce service nous on essaie de
jouer ensemble en famille est donc là on
en profite pour venir voir d'autres
types de jeu qu'on aurait pas nous à la
maison voir ce qu'il nous plaît et
tester des choses c'est trop bien mais
ce qu'un français beaucoup de jeu et on
s'amuse et puis là je me sers un escape
prendre c'était
je reviens en force sous toutes ses
formes placer la forme de jeux vidéo six
jeux de société il ya énormément de
création de jeux vidéo aujourd'hui nous
allons d'ailleurs présents sur les les
événements à villepreux et au mieux
l'aide des créateurs de jeu l'élu dit
dave continue jusqu'au 23 novembre à
saint quentin en yvelines
peut être un moyen de compléter sa
lettre au père noël